[Musique]
depuis le 16 juin les députés de la
commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kovy 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tous les
théâtres cp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui la première
d'entre elles celle de jérôme salomon
dont le visage est désormais bien connue
des français puisque c'est lui qui
chaque soir faisait le point sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie directeur
général de la santé son poste a été
cruciale durant la crise sanitaire
on écoute tout de suite jérôme salon
monsieur le directeur général je vous
remercie de votre présence et je vais
vous demander préalablement de votre
audition à votre audition de prêter
serment
ainsi que la personne qui vous
accompagne en effet conformément à
l'article 6 de l'ordonance de 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires les
personnes auditionnées par une
commission denquête doivent prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité
je le jure je le jure cette période
critique vous a placé vous même et la
direction générale de la santé au
premier plan de la réponse sanitaire
le ministère de la santé a été le
premier à agir avant que le 17 mars ne
soit activé la cellule
interministérielle de crise au moment de
la mise en place du confinement
monsieur le directeur général je vais
vous donner la parole pour un cours
propos liminaire qui précédera notre
échange sous forme de questions réponses
nous devons collectivement tirer toutes
les leçons de la crise sanitaire majeure
et inédite liés à la pandémie massive et
meurtrière de kobe 19
cette maladie nouvelle causée par un
coronavirus émergents dont on connaît
encore mal les caractéristiques poursuit
sa progression dans le monde et inquiète
toujours les experts notamment ceux de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
la première vague épidémique s'achève en
europe et en métropole mais l'épidémie
est loin d'être terminée et le virus
circule toujours de façon hétérogène
comme depuis le début nos équipes
mobilisées au sein du centre de crise
sanitaire depuis le 27 janvier le sont
toujours pleinement
elle surveille la situation en métropole
avec plus de 230 cluster déclaré ou cas
groupés elles soutiennent les équipes en
outre-mer avec une circulation virale
importante à mayotte où il ya aussi une
épidémie de dengue associés et un début
d'épidémie en guyane où des renforts
humains et techniques sont déployés avec
là encore là puis désarmée pour aider à
d'éventuelles évacuations sanitaires si
nécessaire elles sont mobilisés pour
protéger au mieux les territoires
insulaires plus vulnérables assurer la
poursuite de la réponse logistique 3,7
milliards de masques commandés 772
millions de masques déjà distribué et du
dispositif crucial de dépistage des cas
et des porteurs de tests virologiques
dit rt pcr et de repérage des personnes
contactent plus de 1,8 million de tests
ont été réalisés
elles sont prêtes à gérer cet été les
risques de canicule
darbo vie rose et de clusters de covin
19 en évitant au mieux toute diffusion
communautaire mesdames messieurs
une grande majorité des françaises et
des français a retrouvé la liberté au
quotidien et leurs activités habituelles
et c'est une excellente nouvelle
la vigilance et la prudence doivent
cependant rester de mise avec les
nombreux déplacements des vacanciers et
les activités touristiques synonyme de
regroupement
je tiens encore une fois a répété ce
message essentiel nous devons
impérativement maintenir le respect des
gestes barrières des mesures de bon sens
et d'hygiène
la distanciation physique d'un mètre et
le rappel des situations à haut risque
les rassemblements
la promiscuité les espaces clos lorsque
nous sommes nombreux nous devons
anticiper un rebond voir une deuxième
vague épidémique cet automne ou cet
hiver ne pas se préparer à une deuxième
vague serait une faute majeure
nous avons vécu dans nos entourages des
drames
et je tiens ici devant vous à avoir une
pensée particulièrement émue pour toutes
les personnes décédées et leurs familles
je veux aussi évoqué les plus de cent
mille personnes hospitalisés pour une
infection sévère et les malades suivis à
domicile ils ont connu fatigue douleurs
difficultés respiratoires parfois coma
artificiel et réveils difficiles ils ont
pu bénéficier des grandes compétences
professionnelles et des qualités
humaines de nos professionnels de santé
de leur sourire magnifique malgré la
fatigue et de leurs attentions qui font
tant de bien à l'âme
l'immense majorité des malades ducobu 19
sont désormais guéri mais il reste des
milliers de personnes hospitalisées
aujourd'hui des complications lourde à
traiter voir des séquelles à prendre en
charge de façon adaptée
là encore les professionnels de santé en
établissement de santé comme en ville
sont en première ligne
il mérite toute notre gratitude je pense
aux personnels des ehpad qui ont confiné
des personnes qui n'attendent souvent au
cours d'une journée que les visites de
leur famille et la joie d'activités
collectives qui ont transféré des
résidents présents depuis des années
vers un hôpital ou qui ont accompagné
une personne en fin de vie à laquelle
s'était profondément attaché ils ont agi
avec tant d'humanité de dévouement et
d'engagement
je souhaite aussi salué toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont permis au pays de
continuer à bénéficier de ses fonctions
vitales
celles et ceux qui ont souffert de cette
période si particulière
celles et ceux qui ont respecté les
consignes du confinement et du
déconfinement prudent et progressif
enfin je souhaite parler des femmes et
des hommes dont on ne parle jamais ces
femmes et ces hommes toujours dans
l'ombre qui ont géré la crise partout
sur le territoire
à la direction de crise dans les agences
nationales et régionales au sein de nos
ambassades dans les départements et en
préfecture mais aussi dans les cellules
de crise des hôpitaux et des autres
établissements de santé sociaux et
médico sociaux
en tant que directeur de crise et
coordinateur des efforts expertise et
actions je tiens à remercier tout
particulièrement les 319 femmes et
hommes qui se sont mobilisées jour et
nuit sans compter depuis près de cinq
mois au centre de crise sanitaire
le ministère a été entièrement
réorganisé pour accueillir très tôt le
matin et jusque tard dans la nuit
week-end compris ses équipes
remarquables d'engagement et de
compétences qui ont permis avec tant
d'autres au système de santé de tenir
aux malades d'être pris en charge au
mieux en lien étroit et permanent avec
le terrain les établissements les
professionnels mettre en place de
rapatriement aérien et l'accueil de nos
compatriotes de goran réagir un vendredi
à 23h au cluster des contamines-montjoie
projeter une équipe d'appui à la gestion
du cluster de creil trouver et envoyer
du matériel lourd de réanimation
projeter des renforts humains évacué
plus de 650 malades graves ventilé
informer la population et des
professionnels tout cela en gérant
parfois des décès des maladies parmi
leurs proches ou encore les gardes
d'enfants
les internes de santé publique ont
accompli des prouesses en programmation
informatique épidémiologie cartographie
indicateurs de suivi plateforme de
données partagées une équipe d'acheteurs
internationaux à travailler sans relâche
avec des horaires dément en lien étroit
avec le marché chinois
une cellule innovantes de transport
constitué de pompiers de militaires et
de médecins a pris en compte les besoins
en évacuation sanitaire par les airs des
malades et le transport interrégional du
personnel soignant
ce sont quelques-unes des images qui
resteront gravés à jamais dans ma
mémoire
quelques témoignages de l'immense
travail accompli par ces femmes et ces
hommes qui ont porté la gestion de crise
très loin des technocrates désincarné
des bureaucrates coupé du réel des ronds
de cuir qui ne travaillent pas ou de
hauts fonctionnaires froid et désincarné
décrit par certains professionnels
volontaires parfois venus de loin
retraités souhaitant prêter main-forte
étudiants en médecine en pharmacie
élève de l'ena de l'école polytechnique
de l'école des mines de l'école de
guerre ont enrichi des cellules
pluridisciplinaire agile ces femmes et
ces hommes venus de tous horizons ont
mis leurs vies personnelles entre
parenthèses ces femmes et ces hommes ont
fait face depuis 150 jours toujours
attentif au retour de terrain à la
recherche systématique de la meilleure
solution possible
répandent ont besoin avec diligence
créativité et dévouement ils ont aidé le
pays à traverser une crise d'une
violence incroyable je souhaite leur
dire cela nellement et chaleureusement
merci madame la présidente tout d'abord
dans une note datée du 5 septembre 2000
celle adressée l'équipe de campagne
d'emmanuel macro vous alerter sur
l'impréparation de notre pays pour faire
face au risque majeur de catastrophe
vous formulez dans ce même document un
certain nombre de préconisations vous
avez été nommé directeur général de la
santé en janvier 2018
la première question qui me vient donc à
l'esprit la suivante quelle décision
avez vous pris entre votre nomination en
janvier 2018 et le mois de décembre 2020
afin de préparer notre système sanitaire
à 7 à cette éventualité de risque majeur
enfin dans un entretien publié dans le
journal le monde agnès buzyn alors
ministre des solidarités la santé
affirme vous avoir alerté sur ses
inquiétudes quant à l'évolution de la
situation en chine dès le 20 décembre
2019 quelle était la nature de cette
alerte
quelle suite quelles décisions avez vous
prises à la suite de ladite alerte
effectivement je constatais que nous
devons nous préparer à des menaces qui
se font partie des menaces majeures
décrite par l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
ces menaces vous les connaissez ce sont
les pollutions les changements
climatiques ou les impacts des
changements climatiques et maladie
évolutive en particulier et fièvres
hémorragiques virales les pandémies que
vous connaissez déjà comme le vih sida
mais aussi l'impact par exemple de la
résistance aux antibiotiques ou de la
défiance vaccinale et puis les maladies
dites émergente ou réémergente dès mon
arrivée j'ai eu cette approche en
janvier 2018 puisque mon premier
déplacement a eu lieu à santé publique
france 2 prôné une approche globale
une approche que les anglo saxons
qualifient de one health d'anticipation
et donc j'ai poussé plusieurs aspects
d'organisation du de la direction
générale de la santé d'abord nous avons
sorti ce que nous appelons le plan horse
and qui est finalement le pendant du
plan orsec
que vous connaissez dans le champ des
préfets des de la réponse aux
catastrophes
c'est donc la réponse du système de
santé à une situation sanitaire majeur
qui peut être de différentes natures une
canicule une épidémie des risques
éventuellement nucléaire radiologique
biologique ou chimique avec une annexe
très importante qui a été développée
kellan ex risques épidémiques et
biologiques et par ailleurs nous avons
diffusé dans un travail tout à fait
inédit entre la médecine militaire la
médecine hospitalière et la médecine de
ville avec la sécurité civile
la santé et le service de santé des
armées avec lequel nous collaborons un
guide de réponse aux situations
sanitaires exceptionnelle pour tous les
établissements
nous étions en permanence dans ce qu'on
appelle une veille syndromique une
veille sur les dépêches qui sont
partagés désormais au niveau mondial
avec un réseau mondial d'experts et qui
détecte une anomalie de santé des décès
groupe et une épidémie éventuels ou d où
des cas de maladies graves et donc nous
avons effectivement cette alerte qui a
été confirmé par les chinois par les
autorités chinoises à la fin du mois de
décembre concernant une investigation en
cours dans la province du hubei sur des
pneumopathies savait que l'homéopathie
évidemment sont des causes multiples et
donc nous attendions d'avoir des
informations précises des autorités
chinoises
il y a eu des premiers messages que nous
avons suivi avec beaucoup d'attention
dès le début janvier messages qui ont
été confirmés par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé d'abord puis par
les autorités scientifiques nu à ce
parce que vous savez que dans les
premiers jours de janvier a été
confirmée cette épidémie de pneumonie
awan puis la découverte d'un virus
émergents puisque le génome complet de
ce virus a été séquencé et publiée dans
la première quinzaine du mois de janvier
vous avez été vous êtes un des visages
de cette crise
chaque soir vos conférences de presse
ont rythmé la vie des français pendant
le confinement vous avez par le passé
exercé des responsabilités importantes
qui sont également de nature à éclairer
notre commune et notre commission sur la
préparation sur l'état de préparation de
notre pays
estimez vous monsieur le directeur
général que notre pays était prêt en
décembre 2019 ou en janvier 2020 cela
faisait deux ans que vous
copier ses responsabilités lorsque l'un
pharmacie l'information de l'apparition
de ce virus depuis la province du hubei
est parvenu à la france pour faire face
à cette crise majeure qui nous touche
qui nous a touchés et qui risque de nous
frapper encore fortement le monde entier
a été surpris par cette crise totalement
inédite massive rapide brutale mondiale
aucun pays n'est épargné avec d'emblée
des tensions multiples sur l'ensemble
des approvisionnements vous avez noté
que même les grands maux les plus grands
producteurs mondiaux comme la chine ont
été touchés et entièrement à l'arrêt et
on a eu à affronter ce que nous avons
tous vécu des difficultés sur les
équipements de protection ou des
difficultés à obtenir des médicaments
d'importance vitale de réanimation et je
crois que les françaises et les français
ont formidablement réagi à cette crise
nous avons depuis mon arrivée beaucoup
poussé deux éléments importants je pense
ce qu'on appelle des retours
d'expériences systématique ce que les
experts appellent re et ex je pense que
c'est obligatoire désormais et on l'a en
seul est imposé nous avons à chaque fois
qu'il ya eu un événement important
participer rédigez un retour
d'expérience je vous cite des exemples
le cyclone irma qui a durement touché
les antilles les alertes lactalis les
épidémies majeures comme celle du
chikungunya du zika de la dengue
et puis les épisodes intense de canicule
que nous avons subie est encore assez
récemment l' incendie dramatique qu'a
connu rouen avec l'incendié de l'usiné
lubrizol est donc nous en avons tiré des
conséquences nous avons poussé et les
français ont beaucoup progressé dans ce
champ la prévention l'éducation à la
santé
le signalement je crois que la france
est un des rares pays au monde où les
citoyens peuvent signaler des événements
sanitaire grave
nous avons favorisé simplifier le
circuit
des vigilances nous avons grâce à vous
améliorer aussi la sécurité sanitaire
dans l'article 20 de la loi stss
renforcer la lutte anti vectorielle
renforcer les coopérations entre
services notamment avec le service de
santé des armées c'est très important et
puis vous savez que chaque semaine je
préside ce qu'on appelle la réunion de
sécurité sanitaire qui est certes une
réunion santé avec que l'ensemble des
acteurs de la santé
les directions d'administration centrale
les agences de sécurité mais plus
largement la sécurité civile les
directions concernées par les risques à
l'environnement à la consommation à
l'agriculture et donc c'est une culture
de la prévention une culture de
l'anticipation des risques de la gestion
des risques que je souhaite promouvoir
au sein du ministère
d'abord une première question par
rapport aux masques monsieur directeur
général le 4 mars dernier
vous déclariez sur bfm les masques n'ont
aucun intérêt pour le grand public
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous regrettez vos
propos
comme disait voltaire il a été repris
souvent depuis avant de savoir
on ne sait pas nous avons toujours suivi
les recommandations internationales et
fait état avec humilité de ce que nous
ne savions pas et parfois en toute
transparence de ce que nous savions nous
avons agi l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a beaucoup hésité et vous avez
noté qu'elle recommande désormais le
port du masque dans certaines
circonstances
depuis le 5 juin il y à un article je
n'ose le site est parce que on va encore
dire que les revues sont contestables
mais c'est un article dans une revue de
très haut niveau qui a été commandé à
des experts canadiens
et qui vient de sortir qui reprend
l'ensemble des connaissances l'ensemble
des publications ce qu'on appelle une
méta-analyse c'est de comprendre tout ce
qui s'est passé
tout ce qui est sorti dans la presse
scientifique en littérature scientifique
depuis des années pour savoir quelles
sont les meilleures mesures de
prévention sans aucune sans aucun
financement etc
c'est une étude scientifique qui a été
totalement financé par l'aviation
mondiale de la santé et aucun autres
financeurs privés par en particulier et
le premier constat de cette publication
canadienne c'est de dire il n'y a aucun
document consensuel qui démontre
l'efficacité de mesures de prévention en
dehors des mesures barrières que l'on
connaît déjà et en dehors de la mesure
de distanciation physique et même au 1er
juin
ils font état d'un énorme doute sur
l'efficacité des masques je parle bien
des masques grand public 1 c'est
important de le préciser on parle pas du
masque pour les soignants lorsqu'il ya
risque infectieux ou d'un one actes
invasifs ou du masque pour un malade qui
peut contaminer ses proches là on parle
vraiment de du masque grand public et de
l'usaj que par quelqu'un qui ne
présentent pas de symptômes
il ya une vraie difficulté à juger de
cette efficacité et donc depuis le début
il y a eu cette volonté de dire ce que
l'on savait être ce qu'on ne savait pas
vous ne savez pas en particulier si ce
virus pouvait être transmis par ce qu'on
appelle des aérosols
il a été longtemps débattu pour savoir
si ce virus était d'ailleurs responsable
d'une maladie à transmission
interhumaine
il ya beaucoup de publications en
janvier et février sur ce point et donc
nous avons suivi les recommandations des
experts internationaux que ce soit ceux
de l' oms ceux de l'union européenne ou
d'autres experts qui ont publié à
l'international nous avons évidemment
des experts français aussi que nous
avons beaucoup entendu
et lorsque le grand public a voulu des
masques nous avons produit des masques
vous le savez adapter
grâce aux compétences de nos industriels
et de nos artisans en france et donc
j'ai dit très vite je crois fin mars ou
début avril que s'il y avait
effectivement une demandé si nous
pouvions utiliser ce masque non pas
comme une alternative mais bien comme
une mesure complémentaire en plus
d'aider des gestes-barrières et bien
c'était encore une avancée dans
l'éducation à la santé et la prévention
les français ayant déjà notamment
intégrer les solutions hydroalcooliques
et donc nous avons désormais ces masques
produits en france et de grande qualité
qui font partie de cette nouvelle
catégorie des masques grand public et
qui sont désormais utilisés en
particulier lorsqu'il ya une située sur
un risque et je vous rappelle que ces
situations à risques sont surtout les
situations de grande promiscuité de
death pas clos lorsque l'on ne pas
respecter les mesures buy
vous dites vous suivez vous avez suivi
les recommandations de l'om s mais alors
pourquoi sur les tests vous avez fait
l'exact inverse de ce que l'om est sous
a recommandé oms a dit tester tester
tester et en france on n'avait pas
développé de stratégie de test massive
d'après plusieurs remontées de terrain
de nombreux ehpad nous disent en tout
cas ont témoigné s'être vu opposer un
refus de prise en charge de leurs
résidants atteints du coc vide par les
établissements de santé
est ce que oui ou non on a fermé les
portes de ranimation à nos résidents en
ehpad pour vous rappeler l'histoire
nous sommes face à un nouveau virus et
le centre national de référence de
l'institut pasteur met au point le test
en france dès le début janvier il le
transmet très vite à plusieurs
laboratoires sur le territoire
métropolitain et dès la fin janvier
avant même qu'il y ait de nombreux cas
sur le territoire la plupart de ce qu'on
appelle des établissements de santé de
référence disposait de ce test je vous
rappel n'est pas un test facile à
réaliser outre la technique elle mène de
prélèvement qui n'est pas très agréable
il y a une technique de biologie
moléculaire derrière qui nécessite un
équipement en biologie moléculaire
nous avions de nombreux laboratoires
équipés pour faire 1000 depuis 2000 puis
cinq mille tests par jour et s'est très
rapidement monté il ya eu une volonté
aussi de la part des pouvoirs publics de
diminuer le niveau de biosécurité pour
faciliter l'accès de l'ensemble des
laboratoires à un niveau de sécurité de
niveau 2 et très rapidement il y a eu de
plus en plus de tests vous êtes dit tout
à l'heure que le nombre total de tests
réalisés en france et m e désormais de
1,8 million ce qui est quand même très
important
et puis il ya eu une période que vous
comprendrez qu'il était un petit peu
moins
riche en test et c'est assez logique
celle du confinement ou le principe
était qu'effectivement la plupart des
personnes qui pouvaient télétravail et
qu'elle n'avait pas besoin de se
déplacer
restait à domicile et donc il y a eu
cette volonté de passer d'une doctrine
de diagnostic à une doctrine de
dépistage avec le soutient d'ailleurs de
la haute autorité de santé
nous avions une doctrine hospitalière
extrêmement efficace il faut le redire
tout les tous les patients qui se sont
présentés à l'hôpital et qui ont été
hospitalisés ont eu un test
et puis nous sommes passés et c'était
une volonté d'ailleurs assez classique
de de prise en charge classique d'une
épidémie en france s est fait chaque
année pour toutes les épidémies de
gastro entérite de varicelle de rougeole
ou de grippe par exemple d'avoir ce
qu'on appelle une surveillance
syndromique c'est ce que nous faisons
chaque année on surveille par les
médecins sentinelles par les
laboratoires sentinelle les personnes
par des diagnostics qui sont faits par
les par les médecins et pas forcément
par une confirmation biologique n'est
pas forcément nécessaire
et puis il y a eu peut-être une une
difficulté d'interprétation dans les
propos du directeur général de l'est
mais ce qu'ils ne visaient pas la france
mais qui visait bien de nombreux pays
qui n'avaient pas accès aux tests il y
avait encore beaucoup de pays qui
n'étaient pas équipés de laboratoires de
référence et qui a dit on ne peut pas se
permettre face à une pandémie mondiale
d'avoir des pays qui n'ont pas accès aux
thèses parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui
s'y passe est une c'est une inconnue
totale et donc il faut tester tester
tester et nous avons répondu j'allais
dire de façon encore plus volontaire à
la demande de l'om est ce qui est de
dire effectivement nous avons tous
intérêt à tester
c'est ce que nous avons fait et je tiens
à le souligner avec une mobilisation
remarquable des laboratoires savez que
nous avons outre les laboratoires
hospitaliers mobiliser l'ensemble des
laboratoires d'analysés de biologie
médicale des laboratoires départementaux
les laboratoires vétérinaires les
laboratoires de recherche pourriez me
dire que ça va très vite et que ça leur
ait ça aurait pu aller plus vite avec la
seule réserve qui n'est pas une réserve
de compétence c'est que ces laboratoires
ne savent pas faire du rendu de
résultats individuels ils s'affairent
500 tests de recherche et ça faire des
prélèvements multiples dans
l'environnement mais pour rendre un
résultat à lille il y avait cette
nécessité de de ce corps dean se
coordonner avec avec
à laboratoires d'analysés médicales de
belgique a de plus classique
donc nous avons beaucoup progressé sur
la capacité de test nous avons
aujourd'hui une stratégie de tests très
volontariste qui est d'aller chercher
toutes les personnes symptomatique
d'aller chercher évidemment toutes les
personnes porteuses autour de ces
personnes symptomatique d'aller aussi
investiguer très largement autour des
clusters vous savez que nous avons 239
cluster aujourd'hui donc nous avons
vraiment besoin de comprendre quelle est
la circulation virale au sein et autour
de ces clusters
nous allons aussi dans une logique et
c'est assez important pour le signal est
d'aller vers les populations qui sont
des plus éloignés du système de soins
parce qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
populations qui n'ont pas que ce médecin
traitant qui n'ont pas accès à un
laboratoire et il faut que nous
puissions déployer des capacités à
proximité y met un point qui me tais
immédiate de ces personnes et enfin nous
allons et là aussi c'est peut-être pas
suffisamment dit et pour c'est pourquoi
je le redis de plus en plus dans les
dents les points réguliers de la
direction générale de la santé nous
allons vers des lieux où des activités à
risque qui sont des lieux où nous avons
un d'hébergement collectif par exemple
ou une activité à risque professionnel
par exemple parce que de nombreuses
personnes sont dans une atmosphère dit
confiné contrôlés dans un espace clos
avec des difficultés professionnelles à
maintenir les barrières physiques et la
distanciation d'ahmed ce qui s'est passé
au sein de nos ehpad avec nos années
c'était une priorité depuis le début que
d'être extrêmement attentifs au devenir
des résidents des ehpad vous savez que
nous avons travaillé depuis le début
c'est un domaine qui est piloté
évidemment parler d'élection générale de
la cohésion sociale en lien très étroit
avec les fédérations avec ces
établissements qui sont publiques qui
sont privées qui sont pilotés par les
conseils départementaux avec énormément
d'attention
nous avons très vite alerté ses
établissements qui savent ce que c'est
qu'une épidémie hivernale
malheureusement puisque chaque année ils
sont confrontés aux épidémies de grippe
qui ont des équipes qui connaissent
aussi les plans bleus qui travaillent de
façon extrêmement étroites avec des
gériatres avec les médecins traitants
nous avons été très attentifs à prendre
en compte l'ensemble de
de cette activité particulière très
sensible avec énormément d'humanité
parce que chaque ehpad est différente
chaque équipe a une politique différente
et donc nous nous étions très attentif à
ce qu'il y ait un dialogue entre les
familles les médecins les équipes et les
gériatres et donc nous avons beaucoup
travaillé en particulier la société
française de gériatrie vous savez que
nous avons même saisi le comité
consultatif national d'éthique et donc
il n'y a eu dans ce que vous décrivez
comme d'éventuels refus aucune décision
nationale évidemment à chaque fois qu'il
ya une orientation pour un résident vous
le savez c'est une décision difficile
qui est prise avec la famille qui est
prise avec les proches qui est prise
avec le médecin traitant et qui est
prise par un médecin de l'autre côté qui
décide si oui ou non il ya un bénéfice
pour la personne a bénéficié d'un d'une
prise en charge aux urgences médicales
chirurgicales voire de l'animation est
donc cette décision elle est éminemment
individuelle elle est éminemment
médicale et à chaque fois basée sur ce
qu'on appelle le bénéfice risque pour le
patient et c'est donc bien ce qui s'est
passé et nous avons des données qui sont
évidemment public et qui sont rendus
publics toutes les semaines dans le
point épidémiologique de santé publique
france qui démontre bien la répartition
par âge des personnes hospitalisées et
on voit bien qu'en france même si c'est
évidemment pas un titre de gloire est ce
qu'on aurait préféré qu'il n'y ait pas
de personnes hospitalisées dont pour
pour pour que vides mais on voit bien
qu'il y a aujourd'hui encore des
personnes hospitalisées pourquoi vide
qui ont plus de 70 ans plus de 80 ans
voire un âge encore plus avancé et qui
le sont selon les hôpitaux et selon les
pathologies soit en médecine
conventionnelle soit en soins de suite
et réadaptation soit en réanimation si
c'est nécessaire et c'est une démarche
qui reste une démarche individuelle des
équipes médicales et je pense que c'est
ce qu'il faut faire
on sait aujourd'hui que je cette pénurie
de masques que nous avons subie est au
coeur des interrogations nos concitoyens
je crois qu'il faut apporter toutes les
réponses les plus clairement possible
d'abord en nous demandant si vous pouvez
nous dresser un état des lieux chiffré
sur la période actuelle notamment au 1er
janvier 2020
oui me veulent confirmer ou l'infirmer
que sur
la période 2012 2017 il était prévu de
procéder sur les stocks stratégiques
puisque donc les stocks de l'état à une
acquisition de masques chirurgicaux 200
millions par an une première commande a
été passée de 200 millions de masques en
et puis il a été décidé en 2014 de ne
plus active et le marché d'acquisition
et ça a été également un quart en 2015
en 2016 et en 2000 en 2017
pourquoi sur les 500 millions de masques
qui devait être acheté commandé à
l'époque il n'y en a eu que 100 millions
de masques sur la période où vous êtes
en responsabilité vous nous dit tout à
l'heure que l'état de la connaissance
sur les masques ne vous permettait pas
d'avoir une vision d'anticipation bon je
peux l'entendre longtemps en tout cas
votre réponse mais il ya un point qui
m'interroge est-ce que vous avez bien us
cette note de santé publique france du
26 septembre 2018 qui fait suite à
l'expertisé d'un comité scientifique qui
indique qu'il faudrait face à une
pandémie majeure qui toucherait partie
importante de la population
un milliard de masques une boîte de 50
masques pour 20 millions d'habitants ce
qui fait un milliard un milliard de
masques sur la période 2012 2020
avant la crise on commande 100 millions
2013 et 100 millions en 2000 en 2019
alors que l'on sait par l'évaluation de
l'organisme qui succède à l'eprus santé
publique france qu'il en faut un
milliard
parallèlement nous savons et vous savez
en tout cas puisque là aussi santé
publique france commande d'une expertise
à une société belge que la plupart des
masques qui ont été commandés en tout
cas déjà ceux qui étaient commandés en
2013 arrive à une date de péremption fin
d'année 2010 9 et que ceux qui avaient
été commandés précédemment ne sont plus
ne sont plus utilisables selon cette
expertise qui après sera remise en cause
on en reparlera sans doute donc on a un
stock dont les autorités a en charge
connaissent la fragilité qui est en
train de devenir non utilisables on a
une autre qui pose une exigence d'avoir
un milliard de masques et en en commande
que 100 millions voilà pourquoi malgré
cette alerte est sans doute d'autres je
sais pas si vous en avez reçu d'autres
est en tout cas je vous le demande
pourquoi ces commandes ne sont pas
intervenus l'état de la connaissance
étaient posées par des par des experts
et par des institutions en janvier 2020
la france disposait d'un stock
stratégique d'état de 115 millions de
masques chirurgicaux
ce stock stratégique d'état il faut bien
préciser qu' il est un stock qui est
détenu par santé publique france que
c'est une relative exception mondiale
puisque la plupart des autres pays n'ont
pas ce dispositif est que nous avons
cette particularité qui est lié
d'ailleurs à notre histoire nous avons
réintégré 75 millions de masques
chirurgicaux qui était périmé 2019 qui
ont été évalués conforme et donc qu'ils
ont pu être distribués et puis vous
l'avez dit aussi monsieur le rapporteur
il y avait trois cent soixante deux
millions de masques chirurgicaux qui ne
qui ont été achetés probablement dans la
période 2003-2005 sans date de
péremption visible qui ont fait l'objet
de contrôle par le laboratoire national
d'essais par la direction générale de
l'armement et qui ont été classés non
sanitaires mais utilisable évidemment et
c'est tant mieux puisque on a pu en
distribuer 141 millions aujourd'hui je
voulais dit nous sommes sur une commande
importante pour ce stock stratégique et
pour répondre au risque de rebond et de
deuxième vague de 3,7 milliards de
masques c'est un gigantesque pont aérien
c'est aussi une magnifique mobilisation
des acteurs français des masques
sanitaires puisque vous savez qu'ils ont
considérablement augmenté leur capacité
de production sur le territoire national
et donc nous avons déjà 770 millions de
masques distribués premier déstockage
pour les professionnels de santé que
vous avez cités dès la première semaine
de mars mais surtout 687 millions de
masques chirurgicaux à distribuer 7,7
millions de masques pédiatrique et plus
de 78 millions de masques ffp2 le 30
janvier
nous avons commandé pour des équipes de
projection puisque je vous rappelle que
c'était la période des évacuations
sanitaires de one des premiers
premières investigations autour de cas
et donc nous voulions avoir des équipes
parfaitement protégé nous avons décidé
de commander des masques ffp2 pour des
actes à haut risque mais aussi des
équipements de protection individuelle
ce qui n'est pas a priori dans le stock
stratégique d'état de la première pardon
de 1,1 million de la fft 2 le 30 janvier
est de 28,5 millions le 7 février et
puis il ya eu une succession de
commandes nous avons fait des commandes
importantes mais simplement pour vous
donner une idée le le les commandes que
nous faisons c'est 10 à 15 millions de
masques dans un énorme avion gros
porteur
donc à chaque fois que il est à 10 ou 15
millions de masques c'est un avion gros
porteur est en fait un pont aérien de
près de 10 avions gros porteurs
chaque semaine donc c'est vous c'est
pour vous illustrer l'importance de ce
point rien qui ait renforcé d'ailleurs
par un pont maritime et d'autres voies
de livraison ensuite vous m'avez
interrogé sur la période 2010 8 puisque
je suis arrivé en janvier 2018 que vous
donner d'emblée les chiffres parce
qu'ils ont été repris je crois
d'ailleurs régulièrement par par la
presse il y avait des 4,4 millions du
pardon de masques chirurgicaux dans les
stocks stratégiques des temps il y avait
quand je suis arrivé une commande faite
par la dgs et la direction générale de
la santé auprès de santé publique france
d'avoir une évaluation précise de l'état
du stock
vous l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur
ce stock était majoritairement constitué
de commandes en ciel juste pour rappeler
aux membres présents l'histoire des
maladies infectieuses en france nous
avons eu une première alerte avec les
enveloppes contaminés par des du
bacillus anthracis ce aux états unis
forte heureusement pas en france mais
qui ont effectivement et qui était au
début des années 2000 il ya eu
l'émergence du strass dont tout le monde
se souvient mais qui fort heureusement
n'a fait que huit mille cas et 800 décès
avec peu de cas en france et puis il ya
eu les alertes
de pandémie grippale avec eux d'une part
et un virus d'origine aviaire en 2005
c'était le h5n1
puis le h1n1 avec des commandes tout à
fait importante à la fois de masques
chirurgicaux et de masques p2 dans les
années 2010 il ya eu effectivement
beaucoup d'évolutions d'abord une
commission d enquête après la pandémie
h1n1 des évolutions et peut-être qu'il
faut prendre le temps de les décrire qui
ont porté sur la nature et le
fonctionnement de ce soft stratégique la
nature d'abord puisque de plus en plus
d'experts est d'ailleurs la position n'a
pas changé
on jugeait que les masques ffp2 était
réservé à des situations à haut risque
d'incubation de réanimation et donc à
disposer auprès des des soignants les
plus exposés et que les masques
chirurgicaux était effectivement le
masque recours et en particulier pour
les soignants parce que je tient
peut-être rappeler les trois cercles
important pour les masquer le premier
cercle est évidemment la priorité donnée
aux soignants le deuxième cercle
ce sont les malades pour éviter de
contaminer leurs proches et puis ensuite
il ya le cercle dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure des personnes non malades du
grand public est donc cette évolution de
doctrine elle a été basée sur plusieurs
avis d'expert il ya un avis de 2011 du
haut conseil de santé publique il y un
avis de la haute autorité de santé il ya
un positionnement de la direction
générale de la santé
juste pour illustrer aussi le
l'évolution de la nature du risque il ya
eu le maire ce kof qui est apparu
donc là encore un corps en un virus
après le strass en 2012 avec seulement
deux ou trois cas dans la plupart des
pays et puis une persistance de foyers
au moyen-orient il ya eu aussi une
alerte majeure
urgence de santé publique de portée
internationale qui était la fièvre
hémorragique virale à virus ebola en
afrique de l'ouest
et puis il ya eu cette évolution
progressive consensuelle sur lequel les
experts se sont positionnés qui est de
réduire le stock stratégique de masques
en termes de ffp2 et de garder un stock
de masques chirurgicaux avec
régulièrement et évidemment ils
tiendront à votre disposition l'ensemble
des des commandes et des flux d
acquisition des destructions et des
commandes qui sont à la fois sur des
masques chirurgicaux des masques
pédiatrique sur la période que vous avez
cités 2013-2017 le stock de masques
chirurgicaux n'a pas été modifié
puisqu'il était le 730/1000 est resté à
750 milles ont été conseillés de marisol
touraine de 2013 à 2015 et nous avons
durant ces années commandé des masques
chirurgicaux et pédiatrique pour
maintenir le stock de masques jusqu'en
point important la commande de 2017 et
c'est peut-être le point qui qui fait la
jonction avec mon arrivée en 2018 en
2010 est le directeur général de la
santé demande un état précis des stocks
moi j'arrive en janvier 2018 et donc il
y à vous savez cet audit vous l'avez
intercités il ya eu une demande
d'analysé par une société spécialisée
qui a procédé à cet audit et qui a fait
un constat qui nous a énormément surpris
qui était le mauvais état de ce stock
qui massivement majoritairement était
constitué de l'eau de très mauvaise
qualité donc avec de très nombreuses
analyses et qui nous qui nous ont
conduits santé petite france en
particulier à proposer la destruction de
ce stock et je crois que là il n'y avait
pas deux de discussion sur l'état des
masques qui était troué
il ya des enjeux de respirabilité de
contamination microbienne de filtration
enfin je veux pas faire un débat
technique mais pour vous dire qu'il n'y
avait pas de sujet et donc
malheureusement ça a été la découverte
et la très mauvaise surprise de
découvrir un stock massivement périmés
et de très mauvaise qualité et donc nous
avons décidé tout de suite je crois
dans les semaines dans les jours qui ont
suivi en octobre 2018 de commander 100
millions de masques c'était le 30
octobre 2018
pourquoi 100 millions de masques là
aussi peut-être pour illustrer la
démarche que j'avais entamé à la demande
d'agnès buzyn nous avions beaucoup
échangé avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés évidemment puisque vous il ya
les stocks stratégiques d'état qui est
la santé publique france il ya le stock
tactique il ya différents stocks
régionaux et puis il ya les besoins
réguliers que nous observions nous
avions acté une évolution dans ce stock
qui était une évolution assez logique me
semble t'il vers un stock dynamique
verra stop tournant vers un stock tampon
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que nous
considérions que laisser un stop dormant
n'était pas forcément une bonne solution
que ce soap devait servir que ce stock
devait être régulièrement réalimenter
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'un seul coup
l'ensemble du stock qu'ils soient
périmées donc ça paraissait cohérent et
ça a fait partie d'ailleurs des
discussions et des points qui ont été
actés dans ce qu'on appelle le kop
c'est à dire le contrat d'objectifs et
de performance qui a été signé entre
santé publique france et la ministre
agnès buzyn donc que cette évolution
vers une doctrine de stock tournant de
stock tampon et de commandes a proposé
en particulier aux producteurs français
pour leur dire il y à une demande
régulière qui doit être fait pour faire
tourner ce stock et j'ai du mal à
comprendre comment au fil d'épidémie
successives n'est jamais parvenu dans le
débat public
en tout cas pas mes oreilles que ce soit
en tant qu'élu nationale ou en tant
qu'élu local
la difficulté qui était la nôtre
d'approvisionnement en masque ou
d'approvisionnement en test dans la
relation entre l'administration et les
élus nationaux et les élus locaux
je vois une capacité incontestable de
progression mais je voudrais savoir
dans l'expérience éminentes qui est la
vôtre l'explication que vous pouvez nous
apporter sur ce point je me suis
beaucoup interrogée sur le rôle de
l'histoire parce que je pense que il ya
le rôle de l'histoire est là le rôle de
des événements auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
j'ai cité rapidement tout à l'heure les
différents épisodes que nous avons vécu
en france
et fort heureusement il n'ya pas eu d'
enveloppe contaminés au charbon en
france il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de cas
de strass en france il ya eu vous le
savez peu de victimes étant mieux de
l'émergence h5n1 et de la pandémie 2009
et puis il ya eu cette évolution
scientifique cette évolution de doctrine
cette évolution de de posture vis-à-vis
du stock d'état en sachant que là encore
les l'évolution il faut peut être
rassuré les français il y a heureusement
dans l'est dans les établissements de
santé et chez les professionnels de
santé et du matériel on le veut on le
remarque tous les jours et on s'en
satisfait tous les jours les blocs
opératoires bénéficient de deux masques
pour les équipes les réanimations ont
des masses que le dentiste qui kiffent
qui vous opère à des masques mais ce qui
s'est passé je pense c'est une
explication qu'il faudra laisser aux
chercheurs probablement c'est peu de
confrontation ces dernières années à des
besoins importants de masques une crise
totalement inédite qui est quand même
marqué non seulement par sa brutalité
mais par le fait que l'ensemble des pays
demandent le même produit en même temps
alors qu'au quotidien nos professionnels
de santé n'ont aucun problème pour
commander des masques qu'ils soient
libéraux qu'ils soient clinique qui soit
hôpitaux vous prenez l'année 2018 il a
dit 2019
le flux ne pose aucun problème c'est
dans cette irruption brutale d'une crise
ou en particulier les gros producteurs
se retrouvent totalement à l'arrêt voir
utilisent leur production pour eux mêmes
qui nous qui nous a mis en difficulté au
sens collectif puisque la situation est
exactement la même dans d'autres pays
européens
ou qu'outre-atlantique donc une
évolution brutal un stock non
négligeable ce que je voulais je voulais
cité dormant et qu'on souhaitait rendre
plus dynamique et puis peut-être aussi
ça c'est dans le camp de la médecine que
ce que je me place une arme qui peut
paraître entre guillemets moins utile
moins habituel que les armes dont on
parle souvent maintenant qu'ils sont le
fait que la plupart des menaces se pose
des questions d'immunoglobuline de
vaccination d'antiviral d'antibiotiques
de dix minutes d'immunothérapie de deux
molécules extrêmement efficace et on a
l'impression que cet outil de tous les
jours des soignants n'était plus au
niveau international si on prend les
experts internationaux si on prend les
grands consensus internationaux une
démarche que l'on cherchait puisque ce
qu on le cherchait c'était le produit
innovant la réponse anti infectieuse
innovantes ou où la vaccination
immédiate donc voilà ce qu'il ya ce qui
est peut-être le contexte sur votre
interrogation sur le rôle de chacun
je dirais que chacun chaque acteur est
absolument fondamentale selon moi parce
que dans ce que j'ai vécu
personnellement nous avons énormément
échangé avec les acteurs locaux les
maires étaient extrêmement mobilisé les
présidents de conseils départementaux on
parlait tout à l'heure
n'essaie pas évidemment les élus de
terrain les agences régionales de santé
est en fait je pense que les deux sont
absolument indispensables c'est à dire
qu'il faut un état régalien parce que la
puissance de l'état est importante quand
on doit commander massivement quand on
doit discuter au niveau européen quand
on doit mettre en place des démarches de
réponse militaire des ponts aériens des
ponts maritime des vacations enfin ça
paraît logique d'utiliser la puissance
de l'état et notamment la richesse de
tessé forces de sécurité civile ou de
ses forces militaires mais la finesse là
la compréhension du terrain le la
capacité de granulométrie très précises
parce qu'on sait bien que chaque
établissement est différent chaque
organisation de santé différentes fait
qu'effectivement il nous devons nous
interroger collectivement sur cet
échange d'informations en sachant que
chaque acteur à mon sens à un rôle
important est que nous avons appris
pendant cette crise a échangé sur les
besoins et sur les circuits les plus
adaptées en tout cas nous avons nous
sommes efforcé d'être au quotidien l
écoute des acteurs et des élus de terre
je voudrais revenir néanmoins sur la
première question qu'ils ont été posées
par la présente bourguignons qui faisait
référence à cette note du 5 septembre
2016 dans lequel vous disiez la france
n'est pas prête je veux savoir très
concrètement à quoi vous pensiez
notamment sur le plan du risque
pandémique est ce qui a été accompli
pour surmonter ce que vous identifié
comme cette impréparation
vous avez évoqué leurs femmes et leurs
sound souffert de ma part existait déjà
depuis quelques années en quoi vous
l'avez rénové vous l'avez interrogez
vous avez parlé des retours d'expérience
qui est des exercices est ce que sur le
plan de la veille sanitaire
vous aviez une appréciation que vous
nous feriez partagés sur la fusion des
agents sur les éventuels avantages ou
inconvénients que cela présentait sur
l'état de la recherche sur sur l'éco
vide
la question qu'on se pose tous c est ce
que nous étions prêts la veille de
l'épidémie est ce que nous serons prêts
dans quelques mois pour en tirer des
leçons et je voudrais simplement revenir
sur ce que vous avez dit sur les masques
parce que en effet c'est vraiment une
question une question très importante
pour les français je crois comprendre ce
que vous dites que il ya eu un
changement de doctrine en 2018 je sais
pas s'il faut le formuler comme ça parce
que je vous ai question y at il eu un
changement de doctrine en 2018
consistant en réalité à ne pas avoir les
stocks comme c'était envisagé de l'ordre
du milliard mais finalement 215 millions
ou peut-être un peu plus que vous
pourriez que vous feriez tournée et de
quelle manière a été établi cette
nouvelle doctrine fiscale était co
construite avec le secrétariat général
de la défense nationale est ce qu'il a
été validé par des instances politiques
ou
houel ministre hâtives on a besoin
vraiment de savoir ce qu'il en est et si
en effet vous considériez comme madame
busin le 26 janvier comme monsieur vers
ans le 24 février que la france était
prête
quelles dispositions disposer de stocks
massifs et que en cas de nécessité elle
est distribuée face à face à ce que nous
avons vécu on trouve difficilement un
pays qui est qui a été près la plupart
des pays très avancés qui ont plus la
culture de la prévention sont soumis à
de nouveaux des menaces on le voit que
ce soit à singapour que ce soit à pékin
où on est en train de fermer des écoles
qui sont des pays où vraiment le
confinement est extrêmement stricte où
le port du masque est extrêmement
répandu enfin on voit bien que je
cherche cherche désespérément un pays
qui pourrait se targuer d'avoir été prêt
d'avoir parfaitement géré cette pandémie
compte tenu du caractère totalement
inédit massif meurtrier brutal de cette
pandémie
simplement ce que je voulais dire et je
pense que la france va dans le bon sens
c'est quand même important de le dire
nous devons développer et nous l'avons
fait une culture du retour d'expérience
et à chaque événement même s'il a été
bien géré même si ce n'est pas le même
impact
ne devons nous astreindre à l'étudier à
l'analyser c'est vraiment la culture
durée texte or ce n est très récent le
plan en scène est très récent il est
dans son cadre depuis quelques années
mais par contre la déclinaison précise
secteur par secteur
enjeux climatiques en jeu épidémique en
jeu et rbc se met en place dans
l'ensemble du territoire et en
particulier niveau régional même chose
sur la spécificité française qui est de
disposer d'une structure nationale d'
expertise pour la coordination du risque
épidémique et biologique c'est quelque
chose de
2 à signaler puisque ce sont des experts
français infectiologues et
épidémiologistes réanimateurs biologiste
virologues qui se réunissent
régulièrement justement pour pour
évaluer les risques
et puis nous avons une structure qui a
été déjà à plusieurs reprises cité dans
la presse et à l'international qui est
notre capacité de réagir très vite en
termes de recherche d'urgence cela la
structure reacting c'est à dire que tout
tous les opérateurs de recherche en
france travaillent ensemble avec des
structures très réactive et d un cadre
adapté pour pour aller vite
je crois qu'on peut quand même se
féliciter de la frénésie scientifique du
bouillonnement scientifique qu'a connu
la france puisque nous avons quand même
énormément d innovation française tant
mieux nous avions renforcé le circuit
des vigilances du circuit des
signalements
vous savez que nous avons aussi beaucoup
reconfigurer notre paysage des agences
sanitaires et aujourd'hui nous avons des
agents sanitaires qui sont cohérentes en
termes de prise en charge de des
problèmes de santé puisque autour de
santé public français une approche
populationnelle et de prévention qui a
été qui a été poussé nous avons un champ
désormais très cohérent de très haut
niveau autour de l'ansès avec la prise
en charge des enjeux d'environnement de
santé au travail et d'une expertise qui
est reconnu au niveau européen
et puis nous avons l'ensemble du pôle e
produits et pratiques de santé avec l'
agence de biomédecine avec
l'établissement français du sang avec le
la haute autorité de santé avec
évidemment l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament donc voir même
une partie de l'institut du cancer qui
sont aussi sur le champ des pratiques et
des produits
donc on peut quand même vraiment
considérer qu'on a un niveau d'expertisé
en france qui est de qualité on a les
agences régionales de santé qui ont
répondu aux enjeux de surveillance et de
réaction rapide lorsque des premiers cas
sont survenus je vous rappelle ce qui
s'est passé dans la prise en charge de
nos compatriotes rapatriés de one
plusieurs centaines de compatriotes qui
ont été ramenés rapatrié en avion qui
ont été accueillis dans des conditions
tout à fait remarquable par des équipes
soignantes ont été accompagnés pendant
la 14ème dans des centres dédiés donc
vraiment la réponse de terrain a été de
très haut niveau je me souviens je crois
que c'était le 7 ou le 8 février d'un
déplacement avec la ministre agnès buzyn
contamines montjoie où l'équipe
d'investigation de l' agence régionale
de santé et les infectiologues de de
l'hôpital se sont projetés dans ce dans
ce gymnase à proximité de l'école pour
faire des prélèvements le samedi après
midi le dimanche matin pour expliquer à
l'ensemble des parents comment allait se
passer les tests et des résultats donc
le maire était présent
on voit bien que cette que cette réponse
est que cette préparation et que cette
capacité du terrain à prendre en compte
le risque épidémique et biologiques
étaient de qualité donc la france
progresse considérablement je dirais que
les françaises et les français progresse
considérablement aussi dans leur
éducation dans leur capacité à anticiper
les risques à prendre en compte les
risques pour eux-mêmes et pour leurs
proches ils ont progressé sur les
solutions hydro-alcooliques
ils ont progressé aussi sur leur
connaissance du risque infectieux on le
voit le lait les échanges sont de très
bon niveau et donc je crois que la
préparation progresse et que c'est la
question vous m'avez posée nous allons
apprendre ensemble de sept de ces
derniers mois et nous ne serons et c'est
un impératif mieux capable
de prendre en compte un éventuel rebond
épidémique ou une deuxième vague si elle
devait survenir sur la question de 2018
je ne parlerai pas de changement de
doctrine parce que le doctrine c'est
celle qui a été basé par sur sur des
avis scientifiques multiples et sur la
réflexion de la place du masque
chirurgical et ce n'est pas une
réflexion française c'est une réflexion
européenne internationale américaine en
fait il ya beaucoup publication sur la
place du masque chirurgical dans la dans
les mesures barrières en particulier
pour les soignants entre des gestes
invasifs d'à côté qui nécessitent des
masques ffp2 et des gestes de soins donc
la volonté elle était vraiment partagé
par santé publique rend c'est à dire de
se dire que finalement un stock tournant
n'était pas une très bonne idée et on le
voit bien puisque neuf à stocks dormants
pardon elle n'était pas n'était pas une
bonne idée qu on avait plutôt intérêt
tous à avoir des stocks qu'ils soient
régulièrement renforcé rénové
remplacer ça ne paraissait pas du tout
incompatible avec la doctrine mais
d'éviter justement de retomber dans une
situation qui me paraissait pas très
satisfaisant tout on est à jeter
régulièrement des quantités importantes
de masques donc c'était dans les
discussions que nous avions avec santé
publique france dans leur volonté aussi
d'aller vers des stocks tampons vers des
capacités de commande rapide et je crois
que l'effective mans nous avions en
janvier 117 millions de masques je vous
ai parlé aussi des masques qui est en
qui ont été reversés dans le stock de
santé publique france après examen et
donc il y avait à l'époque une
consommation extrêmement faible et puis
il y a eu sept explosions que nous avons
tous vécu dedans dans la dans la
commande qui a fait qu'effectivement
nous avons dû répondre par des commandes
massives et par ce pont aérien
nous avons un très haut niveau
d'expertisé en france et nous pouvons
remercier les experts qui sont mobilisés
on a beaucoup parlé du conseil
scientifique
on pourrait faire beaucoup parler aussi
de ceux qui se sont mobilisés dans les
essais de recherche clinique dans les
essais de recherche vaccinale voir dans
les essais de technologies innovantes il
y en a de très nombreuses que je
pourrais vous citer qui font la fierté
des équipes de recherche françaises
il y a le haut conseil de santé publique
qui a été massivement mobilisés je crois
qu'on est à maintenant près de 60
saisine depuis le début
du mois de janvier donc c'est vous dire
combien ces experts ont pu porter un
certain nombre d'avis il y a le comité
d' analyse de la recherche qui est
présidée par madame françoise barré
sinoussi prix nobel de médecine qui a
éclairé les ministères de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche et des
ministère des solidarités de la santé
sur l'état des innovations
technologiques
l'accès aux innovations l'accès aux
technologies de rupture dans le champ de
la biologie moléculaire dans le champ du
diagnostic dans le champ des innovations
numériques
et puis il ya ce fameux conseil
scientifique qui je pense était
importante pour donner un avis alors
complètement indépendant de l'ensemble
des structures puisque ça a été la
volonté du président la république et du
gouvernement est d'éclairer de façon
totalement indépendante et
pluridisciplinaire parce que je le
rappelle aussi il y avait des
représentants de santé publique france
des représentants du haut conseil de
santé publique mais aussi des
représentants des différentes
spécialités on a parlé de
l'épidémiologie on a vu apparaître un
champ tout à fait nouveau pour les
français qui est celui de la
modélisation mathématique
les équipes françaises sont de très haut
niveau aussi dans les modèles
mathématiques explicatif ou prédictif
donc c'est aussi quelque chose qu'on a
vu apparaître que d'être capable
d'expliquer un phénomène épidémique est
de le modéliser donc un élément de plus
pour éclairer les décideurs je pense que
il est toujours important d'avoir un
éclairage indépendant et une évaluation
scientifique de nos de nos actions en
fait la question qu'on posait c'était
est ce que le pays était prêt nous et
est-ce que les alertes ont été données
pourquoi alors que comité d'experts et
mais une recommandation près de santé
publique france disant qu'il faut un
milliard de masques
pourquoi on reste à 100 millions en gros
il ya qu une commande qui fait 2018 ou
quel est le nombre de masques en période
de crise qui sont nécessaires sur la
réponse
immédiate à la crise et à l' alerte les
premiers messages officiels et cri de l'
oms sont du 5 janvier
nous avons réuni le la réunion sécurité
sanitaire le 8 janvier est le premier
message d alerte qui est partie aux
agences régionales de santé du 10
janvier
allez à l'époque où l' oms disait qu'il
n'y avait pas de targon pour une
transmission interhumaine et la veille
du premier de la première identification
de la séquence virale donc je pense que
sur l' alerte aux ars et aux
établissements de santé et puis ensuite
aux professionnels de santé nous avons
été extrêmement réactif et je vous
rappelle que il y a eu une première
conférence de presse qui a été suivi
ensuite par de très nombreuses
conférences de presse dès le 21 janvier
c'est-à-dire bien avant la conclusion de
la visite du directeur général de l' oms
en chine donc on était vraiment très
très proactifs dans le partage
d'informations de ce que l'on savait ou
de ce qu'on ne savait pas sur la réponse
en termes de stocks en deux ans en 2018
quand j'arrive comme directeur général
de la santé en janvier il y à 750
millions de masques
c'est simplement en octobre 2018 que
l'on découvre que sur 716 sur ses 750
millions de masques
il ya une quantité importante de masques
de vrai qui pose de vrais problèmes de
péremption au sens qualités physiques
mais c'est allé assez c'est vraiment la
surprise est donc avec des enjeux de
respirabilité l'enjeu 2-2 d'efficacité
avec des enjeux de contamination
microbienne que c'est pas possible de
les utiliser et donc on a sept
d'abord cette commande immédiate puisque
je vous le dis je crois que c'était le
le 30 octobre que je commande 100
millions de masques mais surtout qu'on
se met en situation de mettre en place
ce stock tournant c'est à dire de dire
on commande régulièrement des masses
pour refaire ce stock est par ailleurs
vous le savez le ministre olivier derand
a permis grâce à une nouvelle expertise
de transformer ces masques non plus de
masques sanitaires mais de deux masques
grand public parce qu'il y avait une
partie de ces masses qui ont pu quand
même être être repris de même que les
masques 2019 ont été ont été
utiliser et remis dans le dans le stock
puisqu'ils ont été évalués alors sois là
sur les besoins
on était à 117 millions en médiatisant
disponible en janvier 2020 la
consommation de masse qu'en france elle
est de 3 à 5 millions par semaine et
nous avons eu ensuite une augmentation
très régulière jusqu'à effectivement ce
que vous disiez monsieur rapporter 40
millions de masques par semaine mais
nous avons commandé dès le 30 janvier
puis très massivement en février juste
peut-être peau pour dire qu' il y à une
évolution qui a été quand même très
important
la première évolution c'est que les
soignants à l'hôpital et j'en suis un et
je porte le masque depuis très longtemps
ne porte le masque quand il rentre dans
la chambre du malade tout cas c'est
vraiment ce que l'on a comme d'habitude
et de voir d'ailleurs pour ceux qui
fréquentent les hôpitaux régulièrement
vous voyez pas d'infirmière ou de
médecins avec des masques dans le dans
les couloirs vous ne voyez pas de
personnel de santé
la cafétéria ou dans le hall de
l'hôpital portant des masques parce que
le principe est effectivement qu'on se
protège à proximité immédiate du malade
et c'est ça le l'indication et petit à
petit on a vu une évolution
d'abord certains services et c'est une
très bonne pratique comme les services
de maladies infectieuses on l'avait vu
avec agnès buzyn évolué dié verront
d'ailleurs à grenoble certains services
portent le masque en permanence dans les
dents les dans les lieux où il ya des
malades infectieux et une épidémie
hivernale
et puis il y avait aussi cette évolution
qui est que seul expert que vous citez
qui est aussi un expert de grenoble
d'ailleurs le professeur sall avait fait
des évaluations de besoin lors d'une
pandémie grippale pour les malades
c'est là aussi je tiens à préciser parce
qu'effectivement il ya les besoins des
soignants il a les besoins des malades
et il ya éventuellement les besoins de
du grand public et donc il y avait une
constatation qui est que en 2009 les
malades ne porte pas de masque et il y a
aussi une volonté de ma part
d'encourager le port du masque par les
malades dès 2018 et encore plus en 2019
vous avez noté que la campagne
snam 2019 cette campagne qui a eu lieu
en novembre décembre que les français
ont découvert puisqu'elle était très
originale et créative encourager le port
du masque par les malades et donc là
encore il y avait cette évolution
souhaité que les malades pour propos de
protéger leurs proches puissent porter
des masques donc une évolution des
pratiques et une réponse en janvier et
en février à la situation
épidémiologique de l'époque je vous
rappelle que le 15 février
nous étions avec le cluster des
contamines-montjoie et le premier décès
en france et nous avions déjà pons de
commandes et de plusieurs dizaines de
millions de masques et puis il ya eu
cette réponse massive que je redonne
aujourd'hui puisque entre le 16 mars et
le 14 juin c'est à dire en moins de
trois mois
nous avons distribué ce qui est
totalement inédit en france 770 millions
de masques alors que si je ne me trompe
pas environ 140 millions de masques
avait été déstocker en 2009 c'est pour
me donner une idée de de comparaison des
volumes nous étions l'adie est conseillé
de madame touraine chargée de la
prévention des risques sanitaires vous
avez écrit en 2016
emmanuel macron nous mettons pas presque
blâme touraine on avait conscience selon
j'ai informé très régulièrement la
ministre de la situation de sécurité
sanitaire en france puisque c'était mon
rôle de conseiller sécurité sanitaire
évidemment en lien étroit avec le
directeur général de la santé de
l'époque
il faut rappeler aussi l'évolution du
contexte et malheureusement tous les
français s'en souviennent ans et
l'irruption brutale du risque terroriste
en france qui fait que d'un seul coup on
ce qui était totalement inimaginable
devient malheureusement possible entre
mon départ et cette note qui est une
note j'allais dire de réflexion puisque
j'étais avait plus du tout les mêmes
fonctions j'étais enseignant je me
posais la question du
on va dire de la de l'évaluation
générale des risques parce que je trouve
qu'il est intéressant de d'être attentif
justement vous avez cité un peu ma note
qui était qu était global de d'avoir une
espèce de cartographie des risques pour
quelqu'un qui est qui qui veut qui veut
prendre des décisions et donc d'être
attentifs au fait qu'aujourd'hui toutes
les menaces sont globales jeu je suis
frappée en fait par lesdits menaces
majeures qui sont aujourd'hui validée
par par l oms ces menaces concernent
tout le monde
la pollution les changements climatiques
que les émergences de maladie la
défiance vaccinale qui est partagé par
la plupart des pays de la planète
l'antibiorésistance qui parle qui voyage
autant que les êtres humains et la
réponse à des émergences oua oua des
maladies qui peuvent aujourd'hui être
dans une ville très très loin de très
très loin de france et se retrouver en
france le lendemain donc jeu c'était
cette approche là que j'ai voulu que
j'ai voulu favoriser dans ma note à
emmanuel macron c'était une note d'
alerte générale sur le fait qu' il
fallait être attentif au fait que le
monde était devenu un village et que se
détourner de ce qui se passe dans le
monde est aujourd'hui inquiétant il
devait y avoir des contrôles réguliers
de l'état des masques des stocks de
mâcher employeurs dans les
administrations en 2018 vous êtes nommé
directeur général de la santé pour notre
pays avez-vous ordonné des contrôles ou
à vue connaissance de ces contrôles
alors pas ma connaissance que vous
décrivez est très bien c'est
effectivement l'évolution 2011 2013 qui
est une évolution d'ailleurs totalement
cohérente je tiens à le dire
on réfléchit tous ensemble c'est l'avis
d'experts c'est c'est une réflexion
poste événements majeurs de 2009 et donc
je tiens à souligner l'importance de
cette réflexion
c'est une réflexion qui est à la fois
sur le
type de stock sur l'utilisation de ce
stock sur la répartition entre le stock
stratégique le stock dormant déjà parlé
qui est confiée à l'eprus puis à santé
publique france et puis et puis le le
l'évolution vers des stocks locaux vers
des stocks immédiatement disponibles
vers les stocks sur la réalité de
l'employeur vous l'avez très bien dit
que ce soit l'établissement de santé ou
des administrations
donc quand je suis arrivé je me suis
assuré du contrôle du stock qui était
sous ma responsabilité puisque je n'ai
pas activités de l'ensemble des des
stocks des différentes fonctions
publiques ou d où des employeurs privés
ou ou d'autres et donc je me suis
vraiment assuré de de ce stock de santé
publique france qui avait d'ailleurs été
demandée par le directeur général de la
santé qui m'a précédé et dont les
résultats m'ont été fournies par contre
pendant pendant mon mandat
par contre vous le savez c'est peut-être
important aussi de rassurer les
françaises et les français
le stop principal celui qui est utilisé
tous les jours c'est le stock des
établissements de santé publics et
privés
c'est là que la consommation a lieu les
hôpitaux consomme
heureusement tous les jours des masques
et les infirmières on démasque p2 quand
elles sont réanimation les équipes
chirurgicales même chose au bloc
opératoire et les hôpitaux tournent en
permanence avec leurs stocks ils
commandent en permanence des stocks et
ce sont des stocks qui tourne très bien
des stocks qui tombe très bien et donc
il ya entre guillemets pas de problème
de péremption dans un hôpital ou dans
une clinique où les stocks sont
régulièrement utilisés quelles sont les
décisions que le pouvoir politique n'a
pas pris pour bien préparer le pays
parce que il faut nous dire quel était
le niveau d'impréparation du pays la
deuxième chose nous on a le sentiment de
la lenteur monsieur le directeur général
l'an tueur pour les masques on y
reviendra pas d'ailleurs votre première
décision a été de commander 100 millions
de masques lenteur pour les tests
pourquoi en allemagne on est allé
beaucoup plus vite que en france
pourquoi les machines susceptibles de
faire des tests sérologiques été bloquée
avec la chine pourquoi pasteur a traîné
alors que d'autres fabricants de
réactifs était en capacité de nous
livrer ce qui a été fait dans d'autres
pays d'europe et du monde
la troisième question c'est concernant
les traitements
il ya eu là aussi une évolution de la
doctrine
où en sommes-nous et at on laissé de
côté des traitements
tu aurais pu être plus efficace sur les
échos villon expliquez moi comment on a
une disponibilité totale découvrions
pour les micros place pour les
chlamydiae pour d'autres virus et
bactéries ayant n'avais pas pour seul
alors c'était les mêmes qu'on peut
utiliser il y a eu une volonté immédiate
de nos équipes médicales en particulier
pour les malades les plus graves que de
donner un accès au meilleur traitement
je crois qu'il faut le dire parce que
c'est vraiment une mobilisation très
forte que ce soit j'allais dire des
traitements symptomatiques accès à la
réanimation à la dialyse au respirateur
c'est évidemment fondamental mais ç'a eu
lieu dans l'ensemble des réanimations
française je citais tout à l'heure les
660 évacuations sanitaires inter
régionale voire internationale ce qui
est quand même là aussi totalement
inédit mais aussi aux thérapeutiques et
nous avons eu une richesse de programmes
de recherche clinique et une rapidité
d'instruction des des protocoles qui a
été souligné par l'ensemble des
investigateurs l'accès à l'hydroxyethyl
rouquine a été permis évidemment dans le
cadre de recherche clinique et c'était
ça l'important c'était de très
rapidement donner accès cette
thérapeutique ou à d'autres pour juger
de l'efficacité de ce traitement est en
permanence nous avons une balance
bénéfices risques à proposer aux
patients il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons pour la première fois un
résultat positif qui a été dévoilé il ya
quelques heures d'un essai de grande de
grande taille britannique et tant mieux
ça je me félicite que nous a que nous
arrivions par la rigueur par la
mobilisation de tous que ce soit en
europe en particulier
et la bonne nouvelle étant plus que
c'est une molécule ancien peu coûteuse
et accessible nous avons la
dexaméthasone qui est pour la première
fois un molécules qui on va attendre la
publication mais qui semble donner
vraiment des résultats tout à fait
significatif sur la mortalité et en
particulier la mortalité des patients
les plus graves notre stratégie générale
je dirais peut-être puisqu'on en a pas
encore beaucoup parler que la réaction a
été extrêmement rapide dans le partage
d'informations ce qui est fondamental
dans ce type d' alerte votre information
qui a eu lieu dès le 10 janvier dès le
14 janvier puis ensuite nous avons réuni
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
ont leur donner le maximum
d'informations sur la prise en charge et
il y a eu cette volonté d'accompagner
très vite la prise en charge des
clusters d'accompagner les patients
hospitalisés est de développer une
stratégie de test nous voulions que tous
les malades hospitalisés et d'un test
rapidement et d'ailleurs ces deux cas
puisque il y avait une réponse très
rapide dans l'est dans les quatre à six
heures dans l'établissement hospitalier
et tous les établissements de santé en
participer à cette démarche de qualité
pour que dans chaque département on
puisse prendre en compte les malades
hospitalisés très vite
ensuite il y a eu et je le conçois une
discussion sur la sur la stratégie et ça
a été discuté
évidemment avec santé publique france et
les enjeux de surveillance il n'y avait
pas de bénéfice direct à faire le test
alors seulement vous aviez un tableau
clinique compatible il ya ça ne débouche
pas sur une stratégie thérapeutique
différentes
il ya eu aussi beaucoup d'évolution des
connaissances vous savez que nous avons
beaucoup discuté sur le fait qu'une
personne pouvait être asymptomatique une
poupée est personnes pouvaient être
contagieuse avant d'être est
symptomatique énormément de débats je
referai pas toute l'histoire
et puis il ya eu cette difficulté à
convaincre et on le voit encore le lait
les personnes peu symptomatiques d'aller
se faire tester c'est quelque chose de
compliqué de se dire que avec peu de
symptômes il faut quand même aller faire
un test donc on a vu
on a besoin de convaincre tout le monde
et je le redis chaque fois que les
personnes positives avec des symptômes
doivent aller se faire tester c'est un
accès au test important et deuxièmement
il faut il faut que nous que nous
puissions quand même aujourd'hui puisque
l'on parle vous demandiez si nous nous
étions prêts pour demain
il faut aujourd'hui que nous arrivions à
convaincre tout le monde que nous avons
une capacité aujourd'hui de tests qui
n'est pas utilisé pour deux raisons très
claire des deux bonnes raisons et de
bonnes nouvelles
il ya moins de malades que prévu il y a
moins de personnes contactent
qu'anticipé
ce sont deux éléments qui n'était pas
anticipé et donc nous avons la capacité
aujourd'hui un d'aller tester toutes les
personnes positives grâce à la
mobilisation de l'ensemble des
laboratoires sur le territoire national
deux d'être plus invasif plus agressif
autour des clusters pour bien comprendre
quelle est la circulation virale en
particulier dans les zones urbaines
denses 3 d'aller au devant de nos
concitoyens qui sont à distance du
système de santé je pense que c'est très
important d'aller leur proposer des
tests alors qu'ils n'ont pas de médecin
traitant ou qu'ils ont des difficultés à
accéder aux laboratoires et 3 d'aller
chercher cet été en particulier où la
circulation virale devrait être modérée
d'aller traquer les lieux où l'on sait
qu'il ya des facteurs de risque connus
ou le plan international qui sont les
lieux où il ya beaucoup de promiscuité
dans le travail et beaucoup de deux
collectifs dans l'hébergement ou dans le
who dans le fonctionnement quotidien
peut-être moins de virus en tout cas
quand on teste c'est le cas en meurthe
et moselle ont fait beaucoup beaucoup
test du coup on a dit qu'il y avait un
recrudescence en meuse et en meurthe et
moselle c'est juste parce qu'on teste
beaucoup et ça prouve que le virus est
encore bien là je pense qu'il faut faire
vraiment attention parce que déjà entre
le discours de dimanche on va croire que
le virus n'est plus là et vous le savez
très bien c'est pas parce qu'on vous
voit peut être 19 heures
la télé que le virus a disparu je fais
si je pense quand vous voyez aujourd'hui
peut-être que les gens vont comprendre
que le virus est encore là et vu que le
virus est encore là qu'allez-vous faire
sur la situation dégradée des personnels
soignants ils sont dehors vous sans fin
peu gaz et donc sont rentrés à la maison
il travaille en situation dégradée les
surblouse on peut en avoir
on arrive en pénurie de gand est ce
qu'on va faire comme les masques on va
attendre ne pas en avoir pour en
commander
donc là c'est vraiment quelque chose de
vraiment grave
travailler avec des sur vous en sacs
poubelles dont il souffre ils sont
fabriqués en meurthe et moselle c'est
sympa mais là ça devient on en est à
deux mois des situations dégradées faut
vraiment sortir élégant là ça devient
vraiment grave
concernant le deuxième point nous
visions vous voyez à la télé tous les
soirs à 19h mais il a quand même fallu
attendre 15 jours pour connaître le
nombre de décès dans les ehpad et ce
retard de comptabilité ajouté au manque
criant de moyens humains et matériels
dans ces établissements a conduit à
passer sous un silence total de dôme aux
situations dramatiques pour les
directions et personnels d'une part et
pour les proches et les familles d'autre
part pourquoi ce décompte n'est-il pas
paru en même temps que celui des décès à
l'hôpital
vos points étaient quotidiens il aurait
dû être exhaustif et une autre zone
d'ombré demeurent celles des décès à
domicile 1 1 n'a jamais su exactement le
nombre pourquoi même chose je vous avais
fait un plaidoyer pour le test je le
partage totalement il faut qu'on ait
testé plus et en particulier comme vous
l'avez très bien dit plus on teste plus
on trouve éventuellement des porteurs
asymptomatiques donc ça c'est un message
qu'il faut passer cet été parce qu'on va
avoir tendance à baisser la garde et je
pense que nous sommes très attentifs à
la direction générale de la santé au
nombre de tests par habitant par
département il faut que chaque
département soit pas d'avoir une
certaine nombre de tests pour montrer
qu'on surveille même chose on surveille
effectivement la positivité des tests
donc tester toutes les personnes
positives tester même par facteurs de
risque tester autour des clusters tracé
isoler les personnes porteuses et et les
contacts c'est vraiment notre stratégie
vous avez parlé d'un point très
important qui sont les équipements de
protection individuelle ces équipements
de protection individuelle n'était pas
dans le stock stratégique d'état nous
les avons commandées dès le 30 janvier
et c'est une réflexion que nous avons il
faut probablement que nous soyons en
capacité d'avoir des gants des sur blues
et c'est certainement un point à
améliorer je vous remercie de de l'avoir
de l'avoir cité parce que c'est vraiment
le quotidien des soignants à ce faisant
des ehpad me fera beaucoup j'avais été
visiter une ehpad dès le début du mois
de mars ce qui est très compliqué dans
les ehpad vous l'avez dit c'est
effectivement la survenue d'un décès il
ya des décès qui sont survenus en ehpad
et des essais qui sont survenus à
l'hôpital
c'est important et on les compte un jeu
vous pouvez le regarder dans le dans le
point épidémiologique hebdomadaire
et il ya cet enjeu de surveillance de 2
des foyers et de surveillance de la
mortalité en ehpad alors nous l'avons
mise en place cette surveillance allait
maintenant totalement exhaustive dans le
sens où il ya eu aussi un effort
rétrospective c'est à dire qu'on a
repris tous les événements depuis le 1er
mars donc toutes les ehpad ont fait un
travail énorme
juste pour vous dire que les ehpad sont
souvent beaucoup plus petit et beaucoup
moins équipés en personnel déchire que
que les que les établissements de santé
qui sont parfois des gros établissements
avaient des cellules de crise donc il
faut aussi leur accorder cette
difficulté qu'ils ne peuvent pas être au
front à s'occuper des résidents et en
même temps à signaler à faire des
affaires des décomptes et donc il ya eu
un effort important pour que le système
national qui aujourd'hui fonctionne soit
un système national qui ne fasse pas
porter la charge sur l'infirmière sur le
responsable d'établissement parce qu'il
y avait déjà mobilisés sur autre chose
donc on a voulu avoir un système fiable
et vous avez noté que nous donnons
régulièrement le nombre de foyers de cas
de kovy des 2 et 2 et de clusters et
puis évidemment de nombre de décès donc
que c'était ça a été un dispositif qui
s'est mis en place mais qui est un
dispositif quasi unique en europe la
france a vraiment le nombre de talisman
déclarant le nombre de foyers le nombre
de cas le nombre de décès je pense que
c'est effectivement ça pue ça a pu
paraître long pour avoir tous ces
données mais c'est une donnée maintenant
de grande qualité et exhaustive et je
crois que le monde des ehpad et le monde
des gériatres est satisfait de ce
dispositif
parce que il est informatif ils nous
permettent de réagir il permet notamment
de réagir cet été vous avez noter
qu'aujourd'hui on ouvre encore plus les
ehpad et c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour les familles mais nous avons besoin
d'être vigilants sur ce qui va s'y
passer cet été
et enfin votre question très importante
sur les décès en à domicile les décès à
l'hôpital sont surveillés par les
hôpitaux les décès survenus en ehpad
sont surveillés par les équipes des
ehpad qui remonte directement au niveau
régional et national et les décès à
domicile sont surveillés par l'insee qui
a fait un effort considérable pour que
l'état civil soit remonté
très régulièrement et on est maintenant
à une semaine près c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui 16 juin nous avons les
données de la semaine précédente il est
quand même être un exploit considérable
vous savez que nous poussons aussi et
que vous avez poussé et je vous
encourage à le faire si si vous le
voulez à la certification électronique
des décès c'est un point très important
ça permet d'avoir une déclaration
immédiate par le médecin traitant et et
que la mairie immédiatement l'accès aux
certificats électroniques de décès à la
cause de décès pour pouvoir permettre à
l'insee et asante blick france de faire
des statistiques
et aujourd'hui ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la somme des décès survenus en
établissement de santé et celle des
décès survenus en établissements sociaux
et médico-sociaux et en ehpad est à peu
près la même que la sueur mentalité
générale observée par l'insee
merci vous prenez des statistiques de
l'insee il ne semble pas qu'il y ait de
différentiel donc on ne semble pas qu'il
y ait de d'épidémie entre guillemets ou
de nombre important de décès à domicile
et c'est un point très important je
voulais vous interroger sur les masques
je voudrais savoir si vous partagez les
déclarations de marisol touraine qui
expliquent le 7 mai dans le monde que
600 millions de masques ont disparu vous
réagissez
cette formule je voudrais savoir
également pourquoi d'après vous il si
mauvaise gestion des stocks que vous
avez un petit peu décrites avec des
destructions de masques massive
comment se fait-il que on n'est pas un
meilleur turn over et une meilleure
gestion des stocks ne payons nous pas la
disparition de l'eprus dans la gestion
des commandes je rappelle qu'il ya quand
même eu des réquisitions de commandes
faites par les collectivités sur le
tarmac des aéroports
santé publique france at-elle été au
rendez vous notamment la définition de
la stratégie de crise dans la
préparation de la stratégie de
déconfinement est-ce qu'elle a joué son
rôle dans la gestion de la crise dans la
coordination
on a une pénurie à peu près de tout ça
vient d'être évoquée par caroline fiat
je veux savoir là dessus
comment vous regardez les choses le test
était disponible le 22 janvier il était
déjà dans cinq laboratoires des chu le
31 et dans vingt laboratoires est de
hospitalier le 21 février dans une
interview y est il y avait très peu de
très peu de cas en france et ensuite de
façon globale juste que vous ayez les
chiffres a priori nous avons eu 12 1940
test jusqu'au 17 mars 574 millions de
tests pendant le confinement et un
million deux cent mille tests depuis le
depuis la sortie du confinement sur les
masques l'évolution je voulais décrites
elle était effectivement la découverte
d'un stock qui n'avait pas bougé et qui
n'avait pas d diminué en 2010 est sinon
que l'audit demandé par la direction
générale de la santé a démontré que
l'essentiel de ce stock était périmé au
sens qualité c'est ça au fait qui s'est
passé et donc nous mais ça a été
vraiment une très mauvaise surprise que
de découvrir qu'un stock qui était là
depuis 2003 2005 au moment où on regarde
quel est son état en termes de
filtration d'impuretés pouvoir de
contamination microbienne voire même
pire puisque certains étaient même
attaqué par les rongeurs
voilà c'était une très bonne surprise
que dd claude et découvrir ce stock de
mauvaise qualité en termes de en termes
de masques après encore plus important
c'est cesser votre réflexion sur
l'épreuve tous avec l'épreuve a fait
l'objet d'une réorganisation puisque
deux en 2016 à l'eprus a rejoint limp s
est lié mds c'est un une nouvelle agence
santé publique france qui évidemment
assez jeune et qui a pour vocation
justement que d'avoir une approche
populationnelle général puisque on a à
la fois l'amont avec la prévention
l'éducation à la santé tous café santé
publique française vous l'avez
certainement en tête notamment sur
l'éducation nutritionnelle de nutri
score la lutte contre le tabagisme en
fait il y avait beaucoup de mobilisation
autour du plan national de santé
publique
la vocation habituel de surveillance de
la population autour de l'hyène vs au
départ et donc qu'il fait l'objet de
multiples points hebdomadaires dans le
but un climat gildas madère et puis
c'était prusse qui avait vocation à
gérer deux aspects d'ailleurs un dont on
n'a pas parlé qui est la réserve
sanitaire mais aussi beaucoup de
mobilisation humaine autour de la
réserve sanitaire
et puis ce fameux stocks stratégiques et
donc dans le stock stratégique qu'il n'y
avait pas tout on a cité des masques il
n'y avait pas aussi il ya d'autres à
d'autres aspects dans le stock certains
certaines réponses médicamenteuse ou
vaccinale et puis comme le disait madame
la députée il ya aussi des équipements
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui dans
l'équipe dans le stock stratégique et
qui mériterait effectivement une
réflexion pour répondre encore mieux à
d'éventuels besoins massifs des
soignants dans l'est dans l'émoi dans
les années qui viennent sur les
traitements sur les essais cliniques
on a eu le sentiment d'une valse
hésitation de retard à l'allumage une
sorte de fou voudrais vraiment que vous
nous expliquer là dessus notamment sur
l'idh roxy chloroquine pas seulement
mais notamment je crois qu'on a besoin
d'explications enfin sur l'hôpital
public avec un état de dénuement complet
une sonnette d'alarmé a été tirée depuis
longtemps et donc franchement il y
compris sur les lits de réanimation
on a bien france qu'il faut il faut dire
que les livres animations qui ont été
créés n'était pas de même niveau que
ceux qui existaient déjà précédemment
donc j'aurai savoir sur l'hôpital public
est ce que vous avez fait quand vous
êtes arrivé pour prendre la mesure de la
situation sur les essais cliniques vous
nous parler de la recherche sur les
drogues si chloroquine on peut
effectivement il passait un petit moment
parce que comme vous le savez ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup à brûler d'encre on a
toujours soutenu si vous reprenez les
déclarations les faits les essais
cliniques en disant que s'il y avait une
possibilité d'améliorer l'état de santé
des populations il fallait évidemment
proposer ce type de traitement quel
qu'il soit d'ailleurs dès qu'il y avait
une hypothèse thérapeutique une
hypothèse de recherche it aller la
soutenir
on l'a fait avec l'agencé nationale de
sécurité du médicament et des comités de
protection des personnes qui ont
travaillé même le week-end même le soir
pour donner un avis vraiment extrêmement
rapide dont je crois que tous les
investigateurs peuvent dire que la
réponse
deux des autorités en particulier des
instances d'évaluation a été très rapide
ce qui a été peut-être un tout petit peu
compliqué en france ça va vous
surprendre
c'est que c'est le foisonnement des
protocoles c'est à dire ça c'est
peut-être une démarche un peu compliqué
à expliquer mais quand il ya trop de
protocoles sa nuit au protocole c'est
dire qu'en fait comme les patients ne
savent plus dans quel dans quel
protocole entré il ya un enjeu de
puissance dans un essai et donc il faut
avoir beaucoup de patients pour vous
montrer quelque chose
si vous avez des essais éventuellement
dispersez vous avez une difficulté à a1
incorporé à intégrer des patients et
c'est peut-être ça qui sera tiré comme
conclusion niveau européen en
particulier de l'enjeu 2-2 coordonnées
très rapidement les différents
investigateurs mais il ya eu un soutien
européen il ya eu un soutien ou msi un
soutien français ou aux études
chloroquine je vous laisse je voulais
citerai pas de tout parce qu'il y en a
de très nombreuses aussi bien
hospitalières ambulatoires aussi bien
parisienne que qu'en province
et donc on peut dire que nous avons
vraiment testé de très nombreuses
hypothèses
évidemment avec différents bras comme on
le dit régulièrement avec différentes
molécules comparative
mais je crois que on n'a pas à rougir de
nos efforts pour comprendre si oui ou
non il y avait un bénéfice à utiliser
cette molécule ou ou d'autres molécules
et si oui ou non il y avait une balance
bénéfices risques négatifs
après vous m'avez interrogé sur
l'hôpital alors vous savez que le
directeur général de la santé n'a pas ni
les établissements de santé ni des
professionnels de santé sous sa sous sa
compétence puisque je suis chargé de la
santé publique
mais je devrais dire que d'une part en
tant qu hospitalier évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui me touche qui me tient
à coeur que la qualité de l'hôpital
public
dans lequel j'ai travaillé toute ma vie
de la même façon vous dire aussi que je
travaille de façon très étroite et en
parfaite collaboration avec la
directrice générale de l'offre de soins
que les réanimations ont été
exceptionnels en france je sais pas si
vous imaginez ce que c'est que de
doubler une capacité de réanimation ce
que veut dire ce que ça veut dire pour
les équipes en termes de pousser les
murs d'aller chercher des respirateurs
aux urgences d'aller chercher des
respirateurs au samu que de chercher des
respirateurs dans les stocks militaires
ou dans les stocks de l'état
il ya eu des envois de nuit de
respirateurs des envois de nuit d'
équipe d'infirmières de l'animation qui
étaient volontaires pour aller aider en
particulier dans le grand est donc
j'allais dire que l'esprit est bien sûr
toutes les équipes qui sont compétentes
des soignants psychologue pas on peut
citer toutes les personnes il ya une
vraie équipe à nantes dans une
réanimation c'est très très large mais
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il ya une
mobilisation des équipes qui a été
magnifique à une mobilisation technique
qui a été magnifique et il ya eu ces
opérations inédites je crois parce que
mettre plusieurs dizaines de patients
dans un tgv ça n'avait pas été fait
ailleurs avoir des hélicoptères
militaires des avions militaires des
bateaux militaires parce que nous avons
évacuées depuis la corse
ça a été vraiment une très belle
opération alors effectivement après vous
le savez il ya les ségur de la santé il
ya une réflexion en cours de l'ensemble
des professionnels et ce que j'espère
c'est qu'effectivement nous trouveront
des réponses à la hauteur des attentes
des professionnels de santé mais je ne
peux pas aller au delà de mes de mes
compétences et de mes prérogatives comme
disait voltaire avant de savoir on ne
sait pas voilà la réponse de jérôme
salomon interrogée sur ses propos tenus
en mars dernier selon lesquelles les
masques ne présentaient pas d'intérêt
pour la population la suite de cette
audition est à retrouver sur lcp point
fr